hello and welcome to the Daily climate
show coming up today
Dean is on course for its hottest April
Day Ever with four casters predicting up
to 40 degrees this week
his biggest bio energy supplier is told
by its own advisors to stop calling
biomass carbon neutral
and the biggest that showed Brits are
throwing away 80 million items of
perfectly good food every week
hello and welcome to the Daily climate
show where we track the changes to our
world and investigate some of the
potential solutions to The Climate
crisis now Spain could experience its
hottest day in April ever with
forecasters predicting temperatures
could reach 40 degrees this week and the
country's agriculture Minister has asked
the European Union for emergency funding
to help farmers cope with extreme
drought conditions well our climate
change and energy correspondent Hannah
Thomas Peter joins us now from Seville
sohanna temperature is expected of up to
40 degrees this week
yes and it's just so uncomfortable to be
in it's 35 36 degrees here in Seville
possibly a peak of temperatures tomorrow
in this city and a little bit further in
land as well if it creeps above 37.4
that will be a record but it's really
nothing to celebrate this is way too
early in the season for temperatures
like this the city is more than used to
heat it's used to coping with
dramatically High sustained temperatures
through the summer months but we've been
talking to people who have gathered for
the city's annual special Festival about
how early this has come and how worried
worried they are about the impacts on
ordinary life in the city about being
able to get around easily about being
able to work outside people generally
don't emerge from their homes until
eight nine o'clock at night when the
temperatures start dipping so there's an
impact on public health and impact on
productivity and we've also spoken to
some tourists visiting the city who are
really struggling in this heat now the
city's mayor has said that climate
change is going to make this city hotter
and hotter of course we know that
climate change is driving increasingly
frequent increasingly severe weather
events like heat and drought and it's
that drought bit that's causing real
problems uh in this around this city and
across this region Europe had its
hottest driest summer ever last year the
ground is parched and dry it is
absorbing heat and creating this Iberian
oven effect and farmers are now
genuinely worried about being able to
water their crops some have given up
planting entirely and there are concerns
about the availability of water for
people for drinking there may well be
extensive water rationing measures in
place come this summer
Hannah thank you
now the UK's biggest supplier of
bioenergy has been warned by its own
scientists to stop describing biomass as
carbon neutral the Drax power station in
North Yorkshire Burns pellets made from
low-grade leftover wood to produce
energy it was converted from a Coal
Power Station on the basis that doing so
neutralizes carbon emissions because new
trees are planted to absorb them
Drax has been running for for a decade
and the whole the premise on which Drax
was converted to biomass and bioenergy
and the basis on which it's been given
government subsidies for doing that was
that that bioenergy is is very low
carbon or zero carbon and so to be
opening that question up uh now uh it's
certainly a surprising development
well our climate reporter Victoria
Seabrook has been investigating this she
joins us now hi Victoria so what's been
happening here
yeah so this is really all about biomass
which you've just explained which means
burning wood to generate electricity and
that is classed here in the UK and in
the EU as renewable and the idea is that
you plant new trees that suck up the
emissions which effectively neutralizes
them or or zeros them now what I've
learned is that Drax which is the
largest bioenergy supplier in the UK its
own independent scientific advisors have
said actually you should stop calling it
carbon neutral and even reassess your
criteria for doing so and as we've just
heard some are saying that's a little
bit surprising Drax has been doing this
for 10 years so it's had time to sort of
get its get its uh criteria straight to
be revisiting that and and that is the
basis on which it receives huge
government subsidies around 1.7 million
a day last year now the government
andrax have very strongly uh rejected
sort of any suggestion that there's
anything wrong with the way that biomass
is classed in the UK saying it has
helped us get rid of fossil fuels it has
boosted our energy security by having
this extra Supply in the mix but and and
they say that also it can be done in a
way that benefits the environment or has
negligible impact as long as those
strict sustainability criteria are in
place but certainly this raises some
questions some difficult questions some
are saying about well should we actually
be counting some of these emissions
against our tally which would make Net
Zero harder to achieve that's not going
to be desirable for the government and
this all matters because it's emissions
from things like biomass but emissions
in general that are driving climate
change and having these impacts such as
the drought that we've just been hearing
about
okay Victoria thank you
well some of today's other news now and
Asia is experiencing record high
temperatures this month including
Thailand where temperatures have soared
to
45.4 degrees Celsius authorities have
issued warnings for extreme heat and
have advised residents in many parts of
the country including the capital
Bangkok to stay indoors but there is
likely to be some relief as the
temperature is forecast to fall this
week ahead of the rainy season in May
experts have warned that water storage
levels in parts of Italy are less than
half their normal levels after little
rain and meager Alpine snowfalls over
winter the country is bracing for a
second consecutive year of severe
drought reservoirs and lakes are at
extremely low levels threatening
agricultural production
two sites have been named as the first
places to benefit from a 38 million
pound scheme aimed at increasing
rainforests in the British Isles The
Wildlife trust says its Atlantic
rainforest recovery program hopes to
restore the ecosystems which Now cover
less than one percent of the islands the
first sites will be the be on the Isle
of Man and in Northwest Wales
you can't just create a rainforest open
out of nothing it probably takes decades
and decades before rainforest begins to
establish but what it will do that young
Woodland as it begins to grow it sucks
carbon dioxide out of the atmosphere and
that obviously helps us with our climate
change goals
consumers may be spending more than ever
on food but new research suggests we're
also wasting more food than ever before
a survey by the food saving app too good
to go has found that every week Brits
throw away 18 million items of meat and
dairy as well as more than 30 million
items of perfectly edible fruit and veg
and 22 million items of bread and pasta
well joining me now is Sophie Truman
she's the MD for too good to go in the
UK and Ireland hi Sophie thank you so
much for talking to us why are people
throwing away all this food
it's a very good question
um I think the challenge we have today
is there is so much abundance and choice
available for us as consumers when we go
to the shop so I think that leads to us
being slightly picky maybe not choosing
some items because they might be
slightly damaged or not looking the
perfect way and this can lead to a lot
of waste too and then fundamentally when
we're actually at home a lot of people
aren't aware of the difference between
the use by dates and best before dates
um and that that's where a lot of waste
also happens at home so what is the
difference
so use by is for meat and and dairy
items that means that after that date
it's not safe to eat but best before is
frankly a whole different kettle of fish
and that really is just an indication
and a suggestion so it means that the
item is at its very best before the date
but after the day it normally is
perfectly fine to eat so we really urge
people to use their Common Sense uh look
smell taste you know don't waste food
just because it's past the best before I
think milk is a prime example you think
how many times do you throw away pour
milk down the drain because it's past
the date on the packet when actually if
you smell it it's probably perfectly
fine to use is that why some
supermarkets just simply aren't putting
a best before date on some of their
items now
yeah so we've seen a great movement in
the past couple of months with many of
the large retailers removing best before
dates from things like fruit and
vegetables and and that's a great step
um in the right direction but the sad
thing is is that so only 13 of us are
using our senses when it comes to best
before items and you know this this
whole program is talking about climate
change and one of the Staggering
statistics is that at actually food
waste contributes to more greenhouse gas
emissions than the entirety of the
aviation industry so there's a lot more
we should and could be doing at home and
in store to save that food from going to
waste the research was there a
difference or did you see a difference
in the way people use food the way
people throw it away in terms of where
they are in the country or how old they
are
yes we did so looking across the the UK
it was actually londoners which threw
away the most uh sadly with nearly half
of us uh throwing away perfectly edible
food each week and we tend to see that
the older Generations are much better at
saving food versus the younger
generation so there definitely is a lot
more education than that needs to happen
okay Sophie thank you so use your census
thanks for talking to us
you're welcome thank you
well now before we go just a reminder
that you can watch the climate Show with
Tom Heat this weekend that's on Saturday
and Sunday it's at 3 P.M and then again
at 7 30 pm
thank you so much for watching that's
all from us today join us again tomorrow
on The Daily climate show
foreign